ce devrait être l'une des clés de voûte
pédagogiques en faveur du respect de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
pourtant l'éducation à la sexualité
brise surtout par son absence dans nos
établissements scolaires c'est l'un des
constats vous venez de le voir livré par
Ludivine Tommasi dans ce documentaire en
faveur de l'engagement féministe de quoi
s'interroger plus au-delà sur l'enjeu
que constitue désormais l'éducation à la
vie affective et sexuelle face aux
nouvelles générations c'est ce que nous
allons faire maintenant avec nos invités
présents aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous pour commencer
Sylvie Pierre Brossolette bienvenue vous
êtes la présidente du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et membres de la Fondation des femmes
vous êtes également le rappel ancienne
journaliste et ancienne membre du CSA le
Conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel s'il
y a les vit également avec nous
bienvenue
merci vous êtes militante membre du
Collectif féministe hashtag nous toutes
qui s'est fixé pour objectif de lutter
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont sont victimes aujourd'hui
les femmes et les enfants dans notre
pays et vous vous chargez bien sûr
d'interpeller les pouvoirs publics sur
ces questions de violence sexistes et
sexuelles aujourd'hui en France et puis
enfin avec nous Charline Vermont
bienvenue à vous vous êtes formatrice en
santé sexuelle et praticienne en
sexologie vous animez un compte
Instagram baptisé orgasme et moi qui
compte quelques 700 000 abonnés
aujourd'hui et vous former des étudiants
à une éducation dite positive de la
sexualité on vous doit par ailleurs ce
livre corps amour sexualité les 120
questions que vos enfants vont vous
poser un ouvrage publié chez Albin
Michel et Dieu sait si les jeunes
progénitures posent des questions à
leurs sur le sujet et les réponses des
parents ne sont pas forcément simples à
trouver aujourd'hui lorsque on aborde
ces questions en famille dans la cellule
familiale le choix du clitoris dans ce
documentaire ça représentation ou ça non
représentation durant justement
l'éducation à la sexualité procurée
jusqu'ici dans dans nos établissements
vous paraît-il pertinent pour symboliser
l'émancipation féminine aujourd'hui le
sens qu'on doit donner à ces cours à
l'éducation sexuelle et vous nous avez
amené je crois une une peluche
représentant ce fameux clitoris ce qu'on
a découvert en 3D seulement depuis 2015
en France c'est ce qu'on nous dit dans
le film 2016 on le doit Odile fillot qui
ne cherchait française qui on peut
vraiment rendre grâce mais l'anatomie
complète du clitoris tel que vous le
voyez et voilà et aujourd'hui alors je
représente comment il est visible de
l'extérieur n'est-ce pas en fait il qui
est très récent ça date de 1998 une
chercheuse australienne Hélène O'Connell
en réalité voilà donc tout ça c'est
quand même très voilà c'était avant-hier
98 ça me semble un peu réducteur quand
même de se dire que voilà on peut le
choisir comme emblème pour la nouvelle
génération je pense que les questions
elles sont extrêmement larges le sujet
pour moi c'est comment aider ces jeunes
à construire des relations affectives
saines voilà c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
éducation à la vie affective
relationnelle sexuelle et voilà je suis
ravi de pouvoir en débattre avec Célia
Lévy et Sylvie alors c'est ce qu'on va
faire maintenant bien sûr avec ce
premier constat la loi de 2001 la loi du
4 juillet 2001 sur la contraception et
IVG a rendu obligatoire dans l'un de ses
articles l'éducation à la sexualité à
raison de trois cours par an pour tous
les écoliers les collégiens les lycéens
or les élèves aujourd'hui ne bénéficient
que de 13 à 15% de ces sciences
obligatoires soit environ trois cours
sur les 21 cours prévus sur l'ensemble
d'un cursus scolaire allant jusqu'au
lycée et vous dites vous redites dans
chacune des infirmiers que j'ai lu sur
ce sujet nous avons 20 ans de retard
c'est considérable on a pris énormément
de retard alors la question qui nous
vient tout de suite à l'esprit c'est
pourquoi autant de retard la fois
pourquoi et pourquoi c'est grave
pourquoi c'est on le sait multiples
facteurs la complication de rajouter des
heures de cours il faut former des
professeurs ou recruter des associations
tout ça coûte de l'argent il y a une
méfiance à ta vie à la fois du monde
enseignant et des parents pour ce qui
touche à la sexualité c'est encore
largement tabou on a peur que
les enfants qu'on a confié l'éducation
reçoivent des informations que les
parents n'auraient pas dit justement de
la même manière la même manière il y a
surtout un gigantesque problème de
moyens et de volonté politique et avec
des conséquences telles comme maintenant
on s'est réveillé
quels sont les conséquences c'est à dire
que quand on donne pas l'éducation à la
vie sexuelle et affective à l'école les
enfants vont se renseigner ailleurs ils
sont assez gênés de se renseigner avec
leurs parents c'est apparu dans une
enquête qu'on a faite il y a 2 ans au
HSE ils seront ils se disent preneur
tous ces jeunes quel que soit leur âge
d'un dialogue avec des personnes
extérieures à la cellule familiale il
serait moins gêné et
puisqu'il ne le trouve ni chez les
parents finalement parce qu'ils ne le
veut pas ni à l'école ils vont sur les
réseaux numériques et en particulier sur
le porno se renseigner sur comment ça se
passe la relation sexuelles et quand on
sait ce qu'on voit quand on regarde les
séquences porno en accès totalement
libre maintenant un peu moins pour les
mineurs mais enfin dans l'ensemble
encore beaucoup trop libre
des horreurs qu'on peut voir comme si
c'était la norme c'est gravissime ça
veut dire que nos enfants vont croire
les filles comme les garçons que les
pratiques quasiment de torture et de
barbarie qu'on voit sur ces réseaux
numériques c'est comme ça qu'on doit
faire c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
construire des relations harmonieuses et
égales entre les femmes et les hommes
alors nous allons été chercher dans les
enquêtes réalisées par votre collectif
hashtag Bluetooth pour savoir qui
dispense ces séances aux élèves selon
votre étude ce sont les professeurs de
SVT de science et vie de la terre qui
dispense ses cours à hauteur de 61% des
intervenants extérieurs à hauteur de
53%, les infirmiers scolaires 33% et
autres professeurs qui se serait
intéressé au sujet qui aura été formés
pour le faire 6 % seulement quelles
leçons doit-on tirer de ces chiffres
issus de l'une de vos études
essentiellement pour vous en fait
d'abord ce que je voudrais dire c'est la
loi elle prévoit pas seulement des cours
d'éducation à la vie sexuelle affective
mais aussi un domaine sur tout ce qui
concerne la partie relationnelle et la
partie juridique ça veut dire que tout
au long de la scolarité il faut aborder
en fait tout ce qui concerne l'estime de
soi le respect des autres l'identité
sexuelle
l'identité de genre pardon mais aussi
tout ce qui concerne la partie juridique
le cyber-harcèlement la pédocriminalité
l'inceste parce qu'on sait très bien en
fait et s'est mis aussi dans les
communiqués du HSE c'est que la violence
sexiste et sexuelle touche énormément
les jeunes et que si on en parle pas à
l'école en fait on a peu de risques on a
peu de chances qu'on puisse l'éradiquer
donc par rapport à ce que vous dites sur
les intervenants que ce ne soit pas les
enseignants qui se chargent
essentiellement de cette cette formation
mais bel et bien d'intervenants
extérieurs comme le souligne votre étude
il faut peut-être rappeler que si les
associations alors on pense au planning
familial on pense même aux actions les
associations LGBT dans les années 80 ont
vraiment à mettre en place ce type de
formation le nombre d'intervenants
extérieurs c'est comme si l'éducation
nationale avait décidé de déléguer une
grande partie de cette enseignement à
l'extérieur aujourd'hui en croire vos
chiffres l'idée c'est le fait de faire
venir des intervenants extérieurs c'est
aussi des personnes qui sont compétentes
dans leur domaine de compétences et
justement par exemple vous parlez du
planning familial en fait le planning
familial refuse énormément de demandes
actuellement faute de moyens parce
qu'ils ont pas suffisamment de
financement pour pouvoir effectivement
répondre à la demande par rapport à
cette enquête ce qu'on n'a pas dit c'est
que finalement c'est ce que vous dites
aussi c'est que elle est très peu
appliquée la loi puisque finalement la
majorité des personnes qui ont été en
âge scolarité ou qui sont maintenant non
pas ces séances d'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective et relationnelles
d'ailleurs quand on fait un sondage
autour de nous quand on en parle les
gens savent même pas que ça existe donc
justement cette enquête elle a permis de
dénoncer la non-application de la loi et
aussi le fait que finalement il doit y
avoir des référents égalité c'est une
obligation depuis 2018 on avait fait
aussi une enquête et là on a constaté
que deux lycées sur trois n'ont pas de
référent égalité donc c'est des
personnes qui sont formées justement
pour parler de ces sujets et animer en
fait des échanges avec les élèves autour
de ces sujets et on se rend compte dans
le documentaire que finalement quand on
aborde ces sujets ça permet aux filles
et aux garçons de s'interroger sur les
stéréotypes qu'ils ont sur effectivement
les relations qu'ils ont avec les autres
dans un univers qui est complètement on
va dire sécuriser ce qui n'est pas le
cas par exemple quand on sollicite les
réseaux sociaux ou quand on regarde un
film pornographique donc voilà oui et je
voulais rebondir sur l'enquête nous
toutes il y a quand même un rapport
bancaire qui a été réalisé à l'été 2021
qui vient quand même corroborer les
chiffres donc on n'est pas nos confrères
de Mediapart mais qui n'a pas été
diffusé officiellement voilà on est à
15% d'applications de la loi dans les
collèges on est à 20% dans les lycées et
j'aimerais quand même en remettre une
couche c'est à dire là on est en train
de parler d'une application d'une loi
qui prévoit trois séances annuelles
alors j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête deux
secondes et qu'on regarde nos voisins
européens les autres pays de CDE le
Canada on est enfin la barre elle est au
sol je sais pas comment le dire
concrètement mais si on demande aux
Allemands au lycée et vous comment ça
s'est passé l'éducation ils vont vous
expliquer que pendant six semaines les
cours ont été suspendus pour que des
intervenants des associations des
professeurs formés pour puissent
intervenir pour leur délivrer
effectivement tout un voilà tout un
corpus qui leur permettent finalement de
pouvoir faire des choix en conscience
voilà en termes de relation affective en
termes d'égalité etc et qu'on demande
aux Allemands à la sortie du lycée
est-ce que vous avez été satisfait
satisfaite et ben des cours que vous
avez reçus parce que l'Allemagne en plus
finance les études pour voir si
l'application de la loi et voilà à des
répercussions sur le bien-être des
citoyens citoyennes et ben à 76% les
Allemands disent oui mais c'est très
important ce qui veut dire toutes les
deux j'avais complètement en accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit
c'est très très grave parce que la
France non seulement effectivement a
pris du retard ne fait pas ce que ses
voisins peuvent faire très bien dans des
démocraties comparables on devrait avoir
les moyens de mettre le paquet comme on
dit un peu communément et on ne le fait
pas sans se rendre compte qu'on est en
train de fabriquer une société de
barbares c'est-à-dire c'est pauvre gamin
qui n'ont qui n'ont absolument rien pour
apprendre ce que doivent être les
relations consentement effectivement à
une vie sexuelle harmonieuse à connaître
leur corps et qui le découvrent sur des
donne des réseaux sociaux barbares et
bien il fabrique une société pleine de
violence après on se lamente sur le
nombre de féminicides
tant qu'on laisse prospérer les
stéréotypes le sexisme l'ignorance la
brutalité après vous pouvez toujours
protéger des femmes de leur conjoint
violent et mettre les auteurs en prison
si vous avez démarré de génération qui
arrive avec des concept complètement
aberrant de ce qui doit être la vie
en couple c'est c'est il y a plus que
ses yeux pour pleurer donc il faut
prendre le problème mais vraiment comme
une cause nationale là pour le coup
d'accord les femmes le droit des femmes
grande cause nationale mais là c'est
former les enfants qui devient la Grande
Cause Nationale d'urgence sinon on va
faire des enfants malheureux mal éduqué
mal dans leur peau et qui vont faire des
catastrophes de la société après vu
qu'en 2022 2022 il y a deux ans vous
demandiez un plan d'urgence
je suis allé voir le président de la
République il a l'air tout à fait
persuadé quand on lui dit les choses il
a il
acquiesce il dit oui oui non je suis
allé voir Monsieur Papen DIY je lui dis
qu'il fallait beaucoup de choses
obligatoires un référent qui non
seulement et qui est les référent mais
qui soit responsables des programmes et
donc obligatoirement que le programme
soit défini avec un contenu ça rassurer
les parents leur dire mais voilà c'est
quoi le programme pour chaque année
qu'est-ce que votre enfant va voir il
faut qu'il y ait des discussions avec
les parents pour lever toutes les
craintes mais il faut que les programmes
existent soit obligatoire qu'un temps
scolaire soit dégagé enfin tout ça
demande beaucoup de volonté politique
dans un mammouth comme disait l'autre
qui est compliqué c'est vrai que c'est
gigantesque l'effort à faire dans
l'éducation nationale à la hauteur du
retard qu'on a pris mais il faut le
faire moi je rebondis sur ce que vous
avez dit qu'il est hyper important qui
est l'éducation des parents c'est-à-dire
moi j'interviens dans des établissements
scolaires je demande un zoom avec les
parents parce que les parents ont peur
en réalité de ce qu'on va faire en
classe les peurs ont peur les parents
ont peur d'une éducation au sexe je leur
explique effectivement les volets
biologiques psycho émotionnel juridique
mais je pense que là on parle de volonté
politique concrètement les lois elles
sont votées par des députés qui sont
élus par des gens à qui on n'a pas
expliqué en fait l'importance de cette
éducation on le sait aujourd'hui les
études menées montrent que plus on fait
de cours d'éducation à la sexualité
auprès des enfants et des ados c'est
très simple moins il y a d'istes
arrivées sur les 15 24 ans arrivés à la
majorité sexuelle moins il y a de
grossesses juvénile et moins il y a de
violence sexuelles que ce soit côté
victime ou agresseurs
arrivent le premier rapport sexuel
exactement et c'est peut-être
contre-intuitif mais plus on donne des
outils à nos enfants pour faire des
choix en conscience pour monter leur
niveau d'exigence plus les rapports les
premiers rapports sont tardifs donc
concrètement quand vous donnez ces cours
à vos enfants vous les protégez
statistiquement vous les protéger c'est
une histoire de prévention de violence
sexuée sexuelle c'est également une
question de santé publique donc il y a
urgence et c'est ce que j'explique aux
parents voilà surtout c'est qu'en fait
c'est surtout les personnes les plus
jeunes qui sont qui se pissent le plus
de violences sexistes et sexuelles et
donc finalement ne pas en parler c'est
se cacher la face par rapport à un
phénomène qu'elle subisse et donc c'est
hyper important effectivement de de
parler d'éducation sur ce sujet de
déconstruire les stéréotypes parce que
finalement effectivement le le pire
c'est le féminicide mais on a avant le
féminicide on a plus de 210 000 femmes
qui sont victimes de violence au sein de
leur couple chaque année on a 94.000
femmes qui sont victimes de viol ou de
tentatives de viol mais c'est à l'école
que ce cristallise cette terre dans le
documentaire j'ai été très frappé par la
les scènes du début sur les enfants de 6
ans à qui on demande est-ce qu'il y aura
des avantages au nom d'office est-ce
qu'il y aura des avantages ou les
inconvénients à être garçons et aux
garçons est-ce qu'il y aura des
avantages aux inconvénients et des
filles tous les garçons se disent
surtout pas être une fille on aurait que
des inconvénients et on pourrait plus
jouer au foot il faudrait pleurer enfin
on serait plus les chefs et puis les
filles elles disent non non on aurait
que des avantages à être garçons parce
que là on pourrait les dominer on se
ferait pas donner des ordres donc des
six ans les stéréotypes sont ancrées
dans le plus jeune âge avec les hommes
qui sont les chefs et les femmes qui
peuvent subir et bien dès ce jeune âge
là il faudrait avoir cette éducation au
consentement à l'égalité il y a pas que
le sexe il y a aussi tout ce qui va avec
autour le respect et j'espère qu'on
arrivera un jour à mettre de la tête des
garçons qui sont pas les chefs et que
les filles qu'elles peuvent être aussi
chef comme les garçons et ça aussi c'est
l'école c'est important parce que
malheureusement il y a le modèle
familial qui quelquefois reproduit tous
les stéréotypes mais patriarco depuis
Méline millénaires donc s'il y a pas à
l'école pour contrebalancer et puis
éviter de montrer sur les réseaux
sociaux des choses horribles en régulant
le numérique on va continuer à fabriquer
des générations malheureuses et qui vont
faire quelque chose d'important aussi
Sylvie Pierre Brossolette c'est-à-dire
que si on n'a pas une éducation décente
à la sexualité à l'école via l'éducation
nationale via des intervenants
extérieurs cette éducation sexuelle on
va majoritairement la chercher
aujourd'hui toutes les études le dites
sur les sites pornographiques et je
rappelle l'âge médian auquel un enfants
aujourd'hui a accès un site
pornographique c'est 12 ans c'est à dire
qu'autrement dit il y a 50% des jeunes
enfants qui sont déjà sur un site
pornographique avant 12 ans et 50% au
dessus de 12 ans c'est sûr effectivement
c'est hyper important d'en parler à
l'école et c'est pas parlé que de
l'éducation sexuelle en fait c'est ce
qui va tout autour par exemple dans le
documentaire on voit la première image
et dans une cour de récréation on voit
en fait que l'espace est occupé
principalement par des petits garçons
qui jouent au foot et tous l'espace
public en fait finalement elle est
dédiée et à certaines à des hommes et
pas du tout aux femmes donc travailler
sur ce sujet c'est fondamental sur tous
les autres sujets si vous disiez
effectivement finalement il est il est
pas bon d'être une fille la petite fille
dit bah oui les garçons nous tapent moi
je sais que j'ai des personnes qui sont
institutrices qui me disent il y a des
garçons qui tapent des filles parce
qu'ils sont amoureux d'elle donc tout ça
si jamais en fait l'adulte n'intervient
pas s'il y a pas d'échange pourquoi tu
tapes cette petite fille si tu es
amoureux d'elle pourquoi tu tapes sur
elle et voilà donc
et tout ça c'est extrêmement important
et ce que je voulais rajouter pardon
c'est que l'État a une énorme
responsabilité vis-à-vis ça moi je suis
persuadée effectivement que si la loi
était appliquée il y aurait beaucoup
moins de féminités il y aurait beaucoup
moins violences sexistes et sexuelle et
on ne l'applique pas sciemment on
accepte finalement un état de fait qui
fait que les violences sexistes
sexuelles sont massives juste un dernier
point il y a 6,7 millions d'adultes on
estime qui sont victimes d'un cest donc
c'est des choses si on en parle pas à
l'école si on le dénonce pas ça va
continuer et 80% de ces incestes c'est
vraiment le très proche entourage
premier cercle familial ou très très
proche très très proche entourage vous
faites partie de ces personnes
extérieures auxquelles on fait appel
pour transmettre cette éducation
affective et à la sexualité vous évoquez
une pudeur dans le milieu familial dans
les cellules familiales
une réticence à évoquer ces sujets
est-ce que cette pudeur cette réticence
vous la sentez aussi du côté des
enseignants que vous rencontrez en fait
ça peut pas être comment dire on peut
pas imposer à des personnes qui n'ont
pas envie d'en parler de le faire avec
leurs élèves moi je pense que
effectivement quand vous interrogez les
intervenants intervenantes c'est
important je pense de laisser ça entre
les mains de personnes qui sont
compétentes pour le faire qui sur une
base volontaire donc ça peut être
également des professeurs formés il y a
une possibilité de ce format auprès
d'éducation nationale malheureusement
pas en nombre suffisant mais malgré tout
c'est important pour moi de laisser ça
entre les mains de personnes qui ont
envie de le faire et puis pour rebondir
sur ce que disait Célia Lévy on est en
train de parler d'une application d'une
loi de trois séances annuelles parce que
la France voilà a décidé que ça
suffisait ça ne suffit pas je ne
comprends pas pourquoi l'apprentissage
de la relation à soi et aux autres n'est
pas une matière à part entière pour moi
c'est vraiment un sujet c'est à dire si
je vous demande au cours des dernières
24 heures combien de fois vous vous êtes
posé la question de comment est-ce que
je peux exprimer voilà cette ce sujet là
cette pensée là mes sentiments à
personne sans qu'elle ne soit blessées
que je peux mettre ma ligne en fait et
combien de fois vous avez dû recevoir
une limite voilà en essayant d'accepter
le consentement les limites de l'autre
la réalité c'est que c'est notre vie
quotidienne et qu'on va nous sortir du
lycée en nous donnant des apprentissages
qui ne nous serviront jamais
théorème de Pythagore voilà l'hypoténuse
le carré d'hypoténuse combien de fois
vous en êtes servis depuis le bac je
pense voilà par les architectes ça doit
être zéro je comprends pas pourquoi une
un sujet qui est aussi important et vous
avez raison de le souligner c'est bien
au-delà de la sphère sexuelle c'est la
sphère amicale professionnelle pourquoi
ce n'est pas une matière à part entière
voilà il est alors il nous reste 4
minutes je voulais donner d'autres
chiffres
issus d'une enquête nationale de hashtag
Newton votre collectif il s'agit cette
fois des thèmes abordés et ils ont été
aussi abordés dans le documentaire que
nous venons de voir le thème le plus
abordé c'est l'infection sexuellement
transmissible à 82 % les organismes
génétaux masculins 77% le harcèlement
25,7%. le consentement seulement j'ai
envie de dire 22% pour les
[Musique]
faisait plus parler dans leur classe les
garçons que les filles les interrogaient
plus ça installe dès le départ l'idée
que les garçons sont plus faits pour
parler à la collectivité et les filles
moins il y a des tonnes d'exemples comme
ça les manuels scolaires sont bourrés de
stéréotypes et d'image d'hommes célèbres
il faudrait tout regarder il y a
l'éducation sexuelle bien sûr qui doit
être prodigué en tout cas par des gens
compétents qu'ils soient des professeurs
au départ volontaire pour le faire ou
par des associations extérieures peu
importe du moment que le programme est
clair clairement établi pour tous les
les établissements le même ça rassurer
tout le monde cueillez des heures
consacrées mais que ça soit marqué dans
le programme que ça soit pas en plus
parce que sinon ça ne vient jamais il y
a jamais le temps parmi les thèmes
abordés pour faire suite à votre compte
enquête le consentement les violences
sexistes et sexuelles
à l'évidence si on en croit vos chiffres
sont sous-estimés c'est vrai que ce
qu'on se rend compte finalement c'est
que l'éducation elle porte beaucoup sur
l'aspect on va dire santé un peu comme
il y a 50 ans on l'enseignait ou
peut-être un peu moins mais finalement
production et reproduction voilà en plus
la partie clitoris vous citiez qui est
absolument pas qui est très peu cité
d'ailleurs c'est un organe qu'on a on a
on en a parlé publiquement il y a très
peu de temps et le consentement c'est
pareil finalement ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que le consentement c'est
parce qu'on préfère parler de
reproduction que de plaisir peut-être du
symbole de l'émancipation que ça
représente pour les femmes et le
consentement c'est essentiel et c'est
une notion finalement qui a été abordée
il y a quelques années dont on parlait
pas avant mais qui est essentiel c'est à
dire que aussi bien pour les personnes
qui subissent des agressions sexuelles
vous avez violences sexuelles de prendre
de réaliser en fait qu'elles ont vécu
elles l'ont fait sans consentement et à
l'inverse du côté des gens qui qui ont
des rapports sans consentement leur dire
ben non c'est ce que tu fais c'est un
viol c'est une agression sexuelle et
d'ailleurs en fait dans l'enquête que
vous avez faite qui est paru au mois
d'août il y a un conquête du Haut
Conseil de l'égalité
il y a quand même un quart des hommes
qui considèrent que avoir un rapport
sexuel non consentiste n'est pas un viol
et que même à la limite les femmes
aiment ça donc il y a tout en fait ce
qu'on appelle la culture du viol qui est
extrêmement diffusée dans les médias
dans les représentations et à l'école
c'est hyper important d'en parler et
parler de consentement ça permet
effectivement de déconstruire cette
culture
c'était pour lui mars en fait ce sera le
mot de la fin
37% des femmes disent avoir subi dans
leur vie au moins une fois un rapport
sexuel non consenti 37% en 2023 il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans la
société il faudrait essayer d'urgence
c'est dit et vous l'avez dit toutes les
trois d'ailleurs à propos de ce sujet
l'éducation et la sexualité à l'école il
était au cœur du documentaire que nous
venons de voir on ne n'est pas féministe
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag des
badoxes sur Twitter bien entendu nos
invités du jour seront là pour réagir à
ce que seront vos réactions sur ce sujet
j'imagine qu'elles seront nombreuses
merci à Salma Sally qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission je vous donne rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]